come on now
no
[Music]
terrifying video shows an attempted
carjack caught on dash camera video in
California where two suspects Rush a
woman who narrowly escapes
no
investigators say it happened at about
eight o'clock in the morning on July
21st in Oakland California a recording
from the driver's personal dash cam
shows her driving along Skyline
Boulevard
suddenly a white Dodge Charger slows
down in front of her and blocks the
roadway
seconds later two men run straight for
her vehicle
oh
that's when the driver screams and
accelerates past the suspects
[Music]
after that she speeds off away from the
scene
Days Later police announced two men and
a juvenile were arrested in connection
to this and a string of other
carjackings in the area so far police
have not publicly released their names
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie